I've been keeping things light in the
voicemail segment at two one nine to
david p we're continuing that today take
a listen and what's up with it i just
wanted to know your opinion on peanut
butter and jelly sandwich is right if
you thought they were good well if you
thought maybe oh they weren't that good
yeah beautiful question now here's an
interesting thing because i moved to the
u.s. from argentina
peanut butter and jelly is not a thing
in argentina so growing up my parents
had no idea about PB&J they would pack
my lunches and so many people in
elementary school had PB&J i had no clue
what it was eventually I was introduced
to PB&J and I liked it
with the caveats that I don't want
crunchy peanut butter I want smooth
peanut butter and only certain jellies
marmalades and jams make sense
orange marmalade in a PB&J no absolutely
not grape jelly raspberry preserves now
we're talking my friends and a lot of
coronavirus PB&J i think is happening
joining me on the bonus show today we've
got a lot to discuss Pat will join me we
will be back with a new show tomorrow if
you are not privy to the bonus show what
if you could read ten books in just one
sitting that's exactly what one of my
favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinka stand what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in fifteen
minutes
blinka snakes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blankets
to get a sample first just think how
much you can enrich yourself by being
able to soak up an entire nonfiction
book in just 15 minutes
I recently checked out the book podcast
marketing strategy by Daniel rolls and
Ciaran Rogers and so useful so
particularly applicable to what I'm
doing
really recommended blink east has books
on politics philosophy science they have
27 different nonfiction category
and a subscription is only about eight
bucks a month and you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25% off a subscription when you
go to blink is comm slash Pakman I've
put the link right underneath this video